Hello! Test desk! Can you guys hear me?
Sorry, I'm clearing my throat. Anyways, hello! Good morning!
Good morning! Yes, good morning!
What's up?
We're gonna play some of this really cool nice relaxing game
Since it's so early in the morning you just wanna wake up and go back to sleep right?
So this is like a nice chill rhythm game
I think I've seen a little bit of it so I'm curious to try it out
Let's see let's see
Let's see, you're watching while you're at work.
I hope you're focusing.
Or else you might get in trouble.
Not for me though.
I give you the A-OK.
Focus watching.
Yeah, yeah.
It's here in Japan.
It is now 9.30 PM.
I woke up today at 1pm so...
I just laid in bed for a bit, had some breakfast...
And I did some small recordings that I need to finish.
Sort of.
Direct traffic that you're watching. Yeah, yeah. Very funny.
I downloaded a new mobile game. I was playing some stupid game the farming game
Yes 9 30 p.m.
9 30 p.m. I haven't left. I haven't been outside all day today
stocked up on snacks
yesterday last night
after some dance stuff
Now we have a break for a little while
And you gotta do a refresher and then...
Who knows where you guys might see some of our very cool dance lessons pay off, huh?
Where might you guys see that?
Honestly, it's super fun to learn like, um, dances as a group.
That's really cool.
Fest? It might be a little sooner than that.
Oh my god!
Alright, new game! Let's play!
Fuck, fuck.
My space bar.
How's dancing practice?
Well, you guys know already, you know.
I'm pretty good at dancing.
But you know, we had our...
Sensei.
She was very good at teaching us.
So...
Yeah.
Okay, what does it say?
Please beware that this game contains visual effects flashing lights.
Okay, proceed.
You guys hear that? Be aware.
Be aware.
Yeah, I got some skankin' in.
Mm-hmm.
Melts on the rhythm game requires precise timing.
For a dreamy experience, make sure your sound is on and avoid using Bluetooth audio.
Let's start by testing your inputs.
Follow the rhythm and hit space on the beat when moving circles fully overlap with center circle.
Uhh... I'll like... Okay.
Oh... Oh...
Eh... Eh...
Okay...
That's probably right. That's fine. I'm using my keyboard, so...
There should not be much delay except for my... the ping in my brain.
Let's run through the rest of the tutorial.
Melatonin is all about recognizing audio-visual cues and reacting to them at the right time according to the rhythm.
For the first lesson, pay attention to the cues. They will be hinting for you to react on the fourth beat when the circles fully overlap.
Ehh?
Ehh! Look, early!
Ehh!
Every level in the game will eventually expect you to follow the cues without the visual guide.
There will be less guidance for the next lesson, but try to react on the fourth beat like last time.
Okay, I was late twice, but I'm always late, so...
You know, it's fine.
A tempo game, yeah yeah.
This game is pretty recent.
You can get it now on Steam, not as long as it's stream, just letting you guys know.
The levels will have multiple reaction types.
In the next lesson, follow the cues and react with left and right keys on the second and
fourth beat.
Left and right or like WASD?
Umm...
Okay, not WASD.
Got it.
Okay.
There will also be times when you need to start and end your reaction at different times.
In this final lesson, hold space on the third beat and let go on the fourth.
Oh, sorry.
I wasn't paying attention.
I let go late.
Man, I'm stuck already!
Every level in the game will have a unique set of audio and visual cues for you to learn
and follow.
There is a practice mode for each level that guides you through the proper timing, but
eventually you'll just have to rely on following the cues.
If the game feels too difficult, remember that there are various assist options in the
accessibility settings to fine tune the difficulty.
What?
No.
We got it.
That's the end of the tutorial.
Ready to start the game?
Let's go!
Okay...
There's a story mode! Oh my god, this is what my place looks like right now.
I've been snacking on stuff. It's cuz the trash here is confusing.
It's like, you gotta take off, you gotta do all this stuff, you gotta take off the wrapping from the bottle and...
You gotta separate everything and...
You know, I've got piles, I'm working on it.
Alright, oh yeah, I'm assuming I move with the...
Oh, I can move wherever I want.
I can free roam!
I wanna go back to the real world.
I don't wanna be asleep. I already slept too much today.
Dream about food.
Just kidding, I can always sleep some more.
Okay, dream about shopping, food.
Is this free?
I can go wherever I want? Freedom?
Unlock. I have to unlock this one.
Dream about followers?
Wow. You guys are like my followers, huh?
I could totally just dream about you guys.
That happens sometimes. I dream about chat.
I dream about reading chat, responding to people in chat.
Us? What?
Oh no...
Alright, alright. What do you guys feel like? Food, shopping, tech or followers?
I'll let you pick. Sorry if I freeze, it's cause...
My setup's kind of weird.
That's right, dreaming about you guys.
Is the audio okay in terms of like the balance? Supposed to be pretty loud.
Food! You guys, really? You're hungry?
Okay.
Let's go! Practice! We must practice.
Audio's good. Okay.
This stream has three patterns to react to. Make sure you're familiar with how they sound
before moving on to score mode. The last one is a bit tricky.
Practice mode will guide you through this using timing circle and metronome. If you'd
like to be guided at all times, you can enable it in the existing value settings.
Oh. What am I doing?
Oh
I see itself
Pizza
It is useful having the circle.
Was it early?
Okay, okay.
Oh, what early? Too late. 12 perfect!
Okay, I think I'm ready.
I wonder if there's like a remix at the end that has all of them.
Nice, nice.
This game looks nice, doesn't it?
Oh
Byee hearing me say B
Too early!
Okay
Donuts!
Okay, okay.
hearing negative Café
Ah!
I got scared!
I gotta go again
Restart. I think I need to get two stars.
Okay.
Okay, okay, I'm getting it!
Ahh!
My keyboard's too sensitive
What a good Look at that impact!
I had the same amount of misses!
It's the lag, it's the lag!
I don't know why it's hard, like in Rhythm Heaven Fever, I think having the cute characters
helps me a lot.
There's still some levels that I struggled pretty bad with when I first played Rhythm
Heaven Fever.
I just gotta pay attention.
I just gotta pay attention. It's like I do better when I can't see it.
It's because of the sound.
I'm so hungry!
Ah, I wasn't paying attention.
One more time.
I'm hungry! Let me eat!
I'll get it. We restart until there's no mistakes.
Okay.
I'll take one.
I entirely played.
Are you okay?
Hey.
What's going on?
Are you okay?
That confuses me!
What?! What?!
I did one better than last time.
I did one better
I'll add it on my keyboard. Maybe if I play with my eyes closed. Maybe that'll help
I was looking at chat while playing maybe that'll help
Ah, excuse me.
Huh?
Mmm!
Oh no!
Talking takes too much brain power
That doesn't make any sense to my brain!
Ah
I did a little bit better.
Look I'm going down one at a time.
One at a time.
I'm getting there.
I'm trying to play with my eyes closed.
That confused me!
Bum bum bum bum?
Fuck!
Next!
Oh this game is so relaxing though, right?
Haha hehe.
There should be nightmare mode.
Is there nightmare mode?
Where like the aesthetic changes and the pizza's like melting and bloody or something.
Oh, oops.
And the burger's evil.
And instead it eats you.
Nightmare mode! And it's difficult, you know?
I don't get it!
I don't get the one where it scoots closer
No, don't! Go away!
Okay, it said I was too late
Okay, got it.
Okay.
Fakkyo!
This is...a nightmare.
1 to 4?
I don't know how to count.
You guys distracting me?
Not reading chat
Okay
Ah!
Maybe I can afford to miss one.
Or like...
I'm gonna afford to miss one
Or like, two or three.
MMMM.
Ah, I forgot.
I didn't press it.
Ahh!
Bam bam!
I got two stars!
I'm getting better!
Yeah, it's a relaxing game, right? You guys like this song, right?
Don't you guys just really like songs so much, you know?
You just listen to it on repeat.
Again and again and again.
And again.
Okay, last one.
One more, one more.
I can stop anytime, it's true
oh
I always forget when I move the board, I don't know why.
This song sounds so nice, I just get distracted
Give me my fucking donut!
Okay, okay. Look, we got two stars. That's all we need. It said eight stars and there's
four areas. And if you need eight stars, you only need two stars from each area. So, you
You know, that means we did good enough!
Should we go to shopping next?
Quick maths.
Yup, checks out, right? What is this?
In the stream, items will be dropped in specific patterns on the left.
Memorize them and swipe your card in the same pattern on the right.
Oh god, this already sounds complicated.
Wait, am I using the key? Wait.
Space? Oh.
Oh, okay, it's like Simon Says.
Okay, okay.
Ah.
Oops, okay, I see
I was paying attention!
Okay...
This one's easy...
How is this like Among Us? Oh, the swipe?
No! It's not the same, because that one you control with the mouse.
This one you just go...
In this stream, I know some jobs... Wait, did I...
Oops, I meant to do the real thing. Okay
Okay, cute face in the bag
I didn't know it was gonna start until after
oh
How can you do that?
Look!
Okay, okay, okay!
Okay, okay, okay.
I keep thinking it'll go faster.
I didn't know there was gonna be so many items.
We'll do it one more time, right?
You guys want this diamond ring?
I'll buy it.
More.
Now hard.
Now hard! Did I unlock it? Cool.
Oops, I waited too long.
Fuck!!
Okay..
Fuck Design Did You Go 3?
Okay, not that bad. Oh, hard mode! Okay. Now my hand cramping from swiping the card too
Damn, I'm rich!
I can buy so much stuff. I thought at first the bag faces were angry if you were late, but I think it's just random, huh?
Okay, wait. I wasn't prepared. I wasn't ready.
I wasn't ready
I'm ready, let's retry retry
Uhh, oops
It starts so fast!
schlute
Oh
Okay okay!
Okay!
Oh!
Oh, decent. I got decent, okay? Not bad.
It's just...it's hard to get used to. It's starting so fast.
I got one more, one more, one more.
And we move to the next level after this.
Wait, wait, wait. It wasn't ready, it wasn't ready.
No no no...
Sorry.
It's confusing!
Okay.
It starts so fast!
Oh, oops.
Oops.
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Okay, this part's easier.
I
worse than last time I feel like I can get it if it just yeah I feel like
Actually, the beginning is harder for me, because... I don't know.
XD
Oops.
I think I'm gonna go for the
second one.
Okay.
I'm gonna go for the
third one.
Okay.
I think I'm gonna go for the
third one.
Okay.
UUUUHHH
Okay, okay!
Fuck!
I just left a diamond, it's fine!
I did it better than last time!
Okay, okay.
Let's go to the next one!
I'm a professional!
I'm a professional.
Is this self-checkout?
Wow, I got a ring!
Tech.
Check, check, check, check, check
Wake up, wake up!
All the pizza!
Shooting!
Okay, this should be easy, right?
In this dream, shoot incoming enemies
One beat after they appear
Hold on, I gotta clear my throat
Uhhh...
Shoot enemies!
Uh...
One beat after they appear.
Enemies on the bottom row will be harder to hit, since they appeared on off-beats.
Uh...
Okay.
What does that mean?
Okay...
Oh
Oh, okay
Aw.
Dadadada!
Okay, I guess I'm ready.
Those are the offbeat ones.
Okay.
We're gaming.
only
What is that?
Caution?
There's eight Grain
Yay! Zero miss!
Shooting staff...
I think it's better for my brain. This is probably my favorite one so far.
Yay! Hard mode already?
Is it gonna be like a...
Oh good okay not ready!
Oh shit!
Ahhh!
Oh
Okay, not bad, not bad
We're gaming
But this one feels so easy
Too easy
Alright, next
The eyes of this character remind me of like a mob psycho
Like a Reagan
Good to good. It's the guns.
Yeah, I think so.
Okay, only two stars left.
Let's go practice the followers mode.
We're gonna like, cause it's like...
In this stream you'll be jumping from platform to platform.
We're going to Reddit!
After landing, jump when the platform is about to launch you upward.
Don't jump as soon as you touch the platform.
Don't jump.
Phone vibrations will act as cues for the more tricky parts.
This is cute.
A halloween
Cute cute
Cute, cute.
Okay, okay. Maybe I get it.
Oops
I like this one
Okay
There's no drugs, we're just dreaming.
Dreams are crazy.
I dreamt about Crony the other night, actually.
I don't remember what it was, but...
Well, I think she wanted something from me.
And...Scorma, let's go!
I'm gonna fall and die.
What? What? What? What? What? What?
Don't laugh emoji at me!
Am I too early?
Okay, it was too early.
Am I getting them?
I can't tell.
I'm doing it just like in this tutorial!
Speed up!
I'm getting it.
I'm winning.
Oh my god, I'm winning.
I'm winning!
I can't tell if I'm doing it too early or too late.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll close my eyes.
One.
That worked!
Oops, do I win?
Speed up!!!
It's working!
As soon as I opened my eyes, I started to fail.
It confuses me the...
Why does it just vibrate?
Like I have my eyes closed and I hear a vibration and it's just one.
It's like bzzz.
But I don't hear that BOOO!
Where it throws you up in the air so it's confusing!
Nice try, nice try.
Hi.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Does it vibrate? Me and I skip one beat.
Vibrate is because it does a big jump.
Okay, well.
I need to get two stars!
Restart!
Oops, wait, does that count? I don't know, it didn't start yet. I have my eyes closed.
Oops, oops, oops.
okay
okay oops okay
uh i keep opening my eyes
Ahh...
The one where the vibration thing throws me off
Vibrate and then...
Okay
rectangle!
you
What you doing?
Ah!
Ah
Oh, where's the little king?
Okay, okay, I'm getting the hang of it! I'm getting the hang of it!
Okay, so when it goes blue...
It's just that when it throws you up in the air, it's like...
It's so quiet.
I can hardly hear it.
We start...
Maybe it's my headphone, so...
Progress!
Yes, I did better, right?
Missed the less.
Ahh!
I keep pressing it! In the middle of the level change!
Can't be loud.
So close.
Gotta jump jump.
Okay, I have my eyes open. This isn't gonna work.
I can't look. It messes me up. It must be the Reddit symbol!
It's too cute!
I opened my eyes because I was like it's gonna change now right and then I'll end up spamming it. Okay, it's the boom
Why don't you hear that? I mean, STOP!
NES
by
two
Next up.
Maybe if I look it'll be okay this time.
I do better with my eyes
eyes open eyes closed don't look
I want to yell.
No yelling.
Frick.
I hate social media!
and nice relaxing in
I'm never gonna pass!
I'm gonna be stuck here forever!
I'm never gonna pass
I'm gonna be stuck here forever
Now we wait
okay
Okay, okay, speed up!
Oh
Oh, I got it!
Okay.
Yeah, it speeds up at the end.
I think they all have a speed up in every level, huh?
It's like a little speed up or slow down section where they change the BPM or whatever I don't know.
Finally! Two stars. Two stars.
I'm a pro.
I can't imagine the difficulty. Actually, should I try hard?
I just want to try it once before I go into this mysterious whirlpool.
One hard mode.
With my eyes closed only eyes closed only
Oh
Oh frickin' dollar these jumps!
It's okay man.
Chip!
Ch!
Okay, okay, okay.
How bad?
Somewhat.
We got a decent, we got a decent.
Yeah!
We're finished.
We beat the game.
I'm just kidding, I think this is like the first level.
The first mix!
How many mixes are there?
Oh no no no no no!
P Organizations
Oops!
Eh.
Fuck you!
Okay, one store.
Not bad.
And...
Chill beats to study to, right?
Waku, waku...
Waku...
Waku, waku, waku...
Again!
Oh, it's gone!
Hey!
corner.
Shit!
Woops.
Fuck you!
Okay, okay!
Okay, okay.
It's the Reddit part that messes me up.
My eyes closed!
W Trust you
I can still pass two stars with this.
Nevermind.
I can't.
Oh shit.
Oops.
I was reading chat.
I can't.
It does.
Team!
That looks sad
AyOS!
A Idol
Not to...
Ah!
Did I freeze? Okay.
What the heck?
Not two stars. I was so close.
And...
thanks derivative
lil
Fucking hate that one!
What?!
Ooh, no yelling, I'm mad!
Shhh!
Shh, gotta be quiet.
I'll get you.
Huh?
You freegal.
I'm never gonna pass!
I think it's supposed be Rez Rubio.
There's the
do
Look
the
UT're those for.
Us!
Beat them!
Must!
Universities are
Looking
White
Was it
Eh exists
Agh
Fuck you reminded me of you
Next!
Wait a second, I have to get...
Ah, shit.
I thought that might have been it!
This is a pretty game. The colors are nice.
I think I did better on the phone part this time.
this time.
Finally! Yay!
Okay...
Yeah, the social media part is hard.
Cause I look at the animation and I'm like, okay now.
Okay, now!
But then...
It's... I'm always too early.
Ta-da!
Wake up! Time to sleep in a different part of the house!
Night 2.
Are we gonna sleep in the bed this time?
Nah.
That sounds nice.
That song sounds familiar.
What a banger.
Hey, some of the pizza's gone. It's all coffee.
Could you remember about exercise?
Work?
Money?
Huh?
Wow, this will be perfect.
If only the stream wasn't gonna be so short.
I guess if you guys wanna watch me play, you gotta wait until tomorrow.
I might do two streams tomorrow. Oh no wait, nevermind. I have plans tomorrow. I forgot.
I have a guest coming over, but we'll have a stream.
I have a stream there will be a stream tomorrow collab stream if I didn't have any guests coming over then I would do this and
Then new Vegas, but actually I gotta clean
I'm gonna clean up my place cuz it kind of is looking like this
Just a little bit
Just a little bit a collab a guest. It's surprise. It's a secret. You guys will like it
it guys we're gonna like it 30 of it well it's cuz I've been getting home
late and then like I'll just have like some snacks like oh we got some stuff
from the kabini I'm gonna snack on and then I kind of put it away because the
trash separation I'm just like I'll just put it in this general area because I
gotta put all this in a specific place anyways and then I wake up in the
morning I'm like shit shit I woke up late I gotta get ready okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna eat this really quick and I eat breakfast and then I just there's one time where I just left it there where I ate it
After because I you know all the food was gone. So I was like, okay
I'll come back and I'll put it in the in the appropriate trash pile
And then yeah, I gotta clean I got a clean up this place a little bit
We get a hint
Uh...
Might be somewhat similar to some other collab happening today, perhaps...
Somehow connected in some way?
You guys are the investigators.
Put together the puzzle pieces!
I almost said P, just P.
Put together the puzzle pieces.
Similar?
Karaoke? No.
Uh, I don't know. Wait, is it?
Um, I don't know yet.
We haven't talked about it.
It's not GeoGuessr.
It's not with any Myth members.
Oh, I'll have to keep you guys on your toes!
But since we have a little bit of time now, so I probably won't continue this game tomorrow, but maybe what I'll do...
Hold on, I gotta look at my schedule anyways.
I don't know if I have something I'm supposed to do.
I could have done yeah I didn't participate in the apex thing because
there were some scheduling stuff going on with all this 3d stuff happening in
Japan I wasn't sure if I would be able to do the apex tournaments that Ollie's
doing. I told her, I was like, sorry Ali, I wish I could join, but I don't think it's possible
with some stuff I'm doing with 3D in Japan and whatnot. So yeah, I would have participated
otherwise though. So, um, the day after tomorrow? Is that- oh, that's gonna be Ina's thingy?
Oh my god, exciting. After Ina's 3D debut, we can play this game.
Or Fallout New Vegas, either way.
Maybe both? Perhaps both?
Yeah.
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
Okay, that sounds good.
I haven't read the Super Chats in a while since we have a little bit of time left.
I'm gonna read the Super Chats from the stream.
I might be like that for a while where I'll just sometimes I'll read the Super Chats.
Sometimes I might not have time.
Yeah, what time for stream tomorrow?
I don't know. Sorry.
I'm stuck. I don't know.
Probably after like 5pm JST, which would be pretty late for you guys, but you know, it's just the way the world operates on this side.
Where's my thingy?
Alright.
I'm gonna read Super Chats and then I have to end the stream because I got some stuff
I gotta write up.
I gotta write up a report.
AHHH!
Well, time for the game streams.
Probably like...maybe...earliest?
No no no.
Well, the game streams will be on the same day as Ina's 3D debut, so it'll be afterwards,
Which will be pretty late for you guys, so...
Probably be like around 3pm...
JST, which is pretty late for you guys.
Gomenasai.
Gomen-e tsumimasen.
Onto tsumimasen.
Oh my god, it's so embarrassing. I uh...
Forgot my wallet.
Well, I like left my bag
As we went to go do some stuff yesterday
And
Oh yeah, I stopped the convenient was by myself. I was like I'm not gonna go out tomorrow
I'm gonna record and stream stuff
and
I only had like this little coin purse on me, and so I tried to buy some snacks and
And I realized that I was just short like 500 yen
So I was standing at the cash register putting in like little 10 yen coins
My little 30 yen coins my little 1 yen coins
And I was like Sumimasen Sumimasen and there were coins falling out of my pocket on the floor
And then I ended up not having enough after I put in all my coins
Because I had so much change
I didn't have my card so then I had to put it in Google Translate.
I was like, can we remove one item?
Can we remove a few items and do it again?
So I had to remove like two things.
It was a smoothie drink, a healthy smoothie drink and a type of bread.
Maybe it was for the best.
It was embarrassing.
I was like, I was like, Sumimasen! Sumimasen!
And then I ran out.
It was...
Scary. Scary.
No, no, no. The...
The cash person was really nice.
They were like,
Taijuu butte s! Taijuu butte s!
They were laughing.
At me!
Anyways.
Super chats.
Nice mansion, thank you!
A melatonin. I should've named the stream that.
Delna. Thank you.
That's a good JP time.
Konnichiwa-chan, konbanwa.
Kyo wa.
Kyo no haishin wa.
Owari.
More streams at this time, some people say.
No, no, please.
Yeah I haven't, I've also been not streaming so much because I'm trying to stick with the
appropriate time zone for some of you guys.
But also that time passes because that's like the perfect time that I sleep.
So, uh, I'll try to mix it up.
This time is good for EU. All the EU mates.
And I have a JP translator. Arigatou gozaimasu.
Nihongo kawaii.
Zenzen!
Chikau!
Good for EU.
Well, we're gonna have a stream tomorrow.
Not at this time. Probably a little bit earlier than this stream.
Probably? I'm thinking probably, yeah. Maybe like 7, 6 p.m. JST.
I don't know.
Maybe, maybe, thank you. See you in the vlog.
Thank you.
It
From...
Probably from...
I don't know...
Dancing or something?
Maybe it's from...
Bread?
Nah, no, no.
I only got sick after eating Domino's pizza.
The pizza!
It was the pizza!
Yeah, I'm not sure. I'm still gonna eat.
I'll eat gluten while I'm here, and then...
I'll stop when I go back...
When I go back home.
No gluten.
Ah, Amiri-S, thank you. Just in case, you know.
Half-wing, thank you.
How do you think about... Oh, how does it feel to live in Japan?
Uh, it's alright. Yeah, it's pretty good.
All the food is just like too good and I'm like...
Man, I want my home-cooked food, but I don't have any like cooking utensils.
And I'm not gonna buy any because I'm not gonna take it back with me.
So, you know, I'm just eating dinner outside ordering food and I order food and it all
builds up and I have all this plastic and trash and cardboard and you have to dispose
of food like separately and it's confusing.
The food, all the food is too good.
It's too good!
Yeah, it's, it's, you know, it's pretty nice.
Although when I stay inside I feel like I miss so much of-
Because there's such a busy...
Everybody's so busy! Everybody's walking around, you know?
Like the busiest person in the world, everybody's a CEO walking around and I'm-
I'm like staying inside.
I stay inside for like two days.
You know, and I feel like the world just passes me by.
The time here feels different.
You know, when I'm at home, I just lay in bed, you know?
Sit on my couch, look at my fish tanks, and the time just passes by so easily.
But here I'm just like, everybody's out and doing stuff and I'm just in here.
Just watching my anime, playing some games.
And then I go outside and it's like...
Busy, busy, busy, busy, busy.
That's good motivation.
Yeah yeah. Time is so precious here for everybody. Good, it's good. Time should always be precious, right? No matter where you are.
I'm a
Thank you
I'm in the a
Nice backing track we have
Good I thank you
TK thank you. I'm at a donut. I hope I can help you sleep. Maybe maybe I wasn't too loud, right?
Thank you
I've been good about it before, made sure to educate myself and look into everything
I'm like, oh, you know, obviously I knew before, it's like, oh, company in Japan, cool
But now that I'm actually here, I'm actually here and working for, you know, a Japanese company
Pretty crazy to think about
Pretty crazy where you can end up if you just you just keep trying and go with the flow and you know
All done wait out for some opportunities
Pretty crazy
Yeah, I think I just got lucky. I got really lucky
I'm lucky to have you guys too
What a ride. I know it's so crazy. I still can't believe it. I'll be like walking around
I'd be like walking around Japan and I'm like what the fuck am I doing here?
Why am I here?
It's crazy, especially oh like the first day I
arrived back here. I was super dizzy because I hadn't slept in like
30 something hours. I had slept for like a few hours on the plane
Here and then when I got here, I was like, oh, yeah, let's go. And so then I was like, let's go
Let's go play some claw machines or something
And then
Yeah, I was up for a really long time and I was super dizzy walking around I'd be like staring at the ground like
My am I dreaming is this real?
I'm so dizzy
And but I play claw machine anyways, it was fun
And then I had a nice long sleep
Oh, so champs, thank you!
Any...
Offline co-op mo- oh, game?
Offline co-op games?
Yeah, that'd be fun. We're planning some stuff.
Some things.
Now, Jimmy-san, arigato!
A-me-chan kawaii!
No, no.
Fong dang source, thank you.
Slack armor, thank you.
Rhythm game homework for dance lessons.
Yeah, um...
My rhythm is pretty good.
You know, a lot of...
You guys could tell, right? While watching, right? It's pretty good.
I, uh...
I have some more dance lessons coming up, so...
Looking forward to them.
It really helps...
Having...
Somebody teach you and...
Be there as like a reference
Thank you!
Oh wait
Change your name
Not Niwa
Wani
Wait, didn't we learn this?
Well then I gotta clear my throat too
Wrong thing
Okay
Gator
Wani
Thank you!
Subaru Senpai
I saw her briefly
But just briefly, I uh...
Was being rushed into a meeting
Cause I was late, so I was like
Oh!
Oh! Hello!
Hello! Oh! Okay, bye!
Pretty much
Envy, thank you
Today's a good day
I'm glad
Oh my god, translate this.
Thank you.
Translate this too.
Inseo. Wait.
Yeah. Inseo.
Thank you.
David C. Thank you.
Game looks good.
I'm going to translate this.
Thank you.
Oh, game looks good. Yeah, I'm glad um, I don't know who
Requested this game, but I was like too lazy to request this game, even though I saw it a long time ago
So I'm glad that I randomly found it today because I was like
What am I gonna stream? I don't wanna, I mean I wanna play in New Vegas, but I don't like having
Streams. Oh god, am I dead?
I don't like having so many streams in a row
I don't know
Hellsinging, thank you
Thank you, I appreciate the support
Into Mopi, thank you
Metal Hellsinger might be a nightmare mode
Is that a game?
Yeah, they should do nightmare mode of this
Spooky
And then they should have the songs but like
As metal or something instead
It reminds me of that one game, Rainbow Unicorn.
Didn't they have a version like that? I think.
Dorgio, thank you.
I heard you used Rococo mocap suit for Kiara's birthday a couple months ago.
No, we did not use that for her birthday, no.
It was different technology.
Rococo suit is pretty good, yeah.
It's pretty expensive if you have the money if you're willing to spend it.
They're always making improvements on the software so yeah it's pretty good it can be pretty good.
Thank you.
Moku moku moku.
Moku moku yummy.
Is there a low-fi version of moku moku yummy?
Wang shouren, thank you.
Road to Pic, thank you!
Thank you for watching!
Map 10 8, thank you!
Ah yeah, I like the shooting one the best so far, but...
We'll have to see what other levels there are
Cause I have no idea, I've only seen like a few different...
Things from this game before
So I'm interested to see what the other ones are
I'm back in a dream with these stages.
Thank you for the gifted memberships!
Thank you! Eleven gifted memberships in total.
Thank you. Can I say I'm saying thank you?
Good morning!
Eggtone44, thank you! Good morning!
I'm back in dream with these stages
Yeah, they're cool
The art is nice
Here's the name, say thank you
Yeah, I can't do that part
I'm gonna listen to karaoke yet
I'm just gonna finish up these super chats and then say goodbye
It's so awesome, say thank you
I'm glad you enjoyed, thank you for watching
TK, thank you
molding i'm not molding i have all my hair
chanli thank you gram thank you thank you for watching
nate the face thank you shoot me thank you
it's not pico i have okay i just had a bike accident oh thank you
What does that say? Thank you
Check up, yeah! Thank you!
Ooh, bedtime
Bedtime, goodnight
Can I say I'm saying...thank you
Ah, thank you
Yeah, I'm gonna sleep a little bit more
Well, I'll clean
I gotta write up some stuff and then...
I'll sleep
I'll do some more cleaning tomorrow
Cause I'm not gonna...I gotta vacuum
But I'm not gonna vacuum right now
Not preferable
I said it right
Thank you! Thank you for watching!
Thank you!
Oh, nice!
Relaxing rhythm game to listen to at work
I know, it's so exciting! I can't wait to watch Ina's...
Stream
Her 3D debut!
I got to see a little bit of rehearsal, and it's super cute!
That's it for today! Thank you!
Thank you
Because I must.
Game 8910, thank you.
A morning stream, get to watch instead of doing work.
No, no, no. Get back to work. This dream's ending.
Jojo1229, thank you.
Import bread from Japan now.
Yeah, we'll see.
I think I am better when it's...
Japan, Japanese gluten.
But I'm gonna do some more experimenting once I'm completely off gluten when I go back home.
And then I'll try something that's like...
You know, American gluten or something like that.
And then like another country.
And just see if anything happens.
JHGardener, thank you!
Oh, thank you. Yeah, dancing has been pretty fun.
Oh, oh, stuck!
Oh, today's thank you! 9AM EST, so it's not bad.
Whatever time works best.
Yeah, it'll be probably pretty early in the morning for you guys.
Dancing's been super fun.
Just in time! Ah, thank you!
Kourasai! Ah, thank you!
I know, it's so nice to just... I'm just like the type of person...
I just like to be alone. You know, inside, alone.
Sometimes doing nothing.
Sometimes just existing.
But definitely it feels like the time passes by...
In the worst way possible.
When I go outside and...
Everybody's, you know, living their life.
Busy as heck.
Doing all the cool stuff.
But for now, just focusing on working hard.
And then we'll take some breaks and do some fun stuff.
Fusquia-la, thank you.
As well, down.
Yuen Xing, thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Belated Valentine's Chocolate.
Ooh, I booked the Halloween Collab Cafe.
Nice, yeah.
Book while you can.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm looking forward to it.
We've done some special stuff at the Collab Cafe.
It opened recently.
So, it'll be pretty cool.
And then...
What was I gonna say?
Oh yeah! And then...on White Day...
I wonder what we'll do. Actually, I don't know...
Is that...what day is that again?
March...14th?
Oh? Isn't that Pi Day?
I'll go to Halyun Cafe! Yatta!
And Miku Day. White Day Miku Day, Pie Day.
There's too many holidays!
Alright.
Yeah, we'll do something.
And Crony's birthday?
We might have to celebrate White Day like a day later or something.
Maybe a day early.
Bubba Day?
No, it wasn't that in January
Wait, what day is it?
Miku is 3-9?
Oh yeah
That makes sense
That's it
G086, thank you
Meiten, thank you
During work
Tsk tsk
Attack a goalie, thank you
Oh, nice
Thank you, thank you
Have a nice day
Alpha9571, thank you!
Oh, thank you!
TK, thank you!
Yes, everybody's working really hard.
We've been working and waiting...
for this time for our 3D debut in Japan!
Everybody, shoot that...
Uh, have you sniffed all of Halloween yet?
No, not yet.
I don't know, I'm a mouth breather, so I don't like...
I don't really...
You know, it's not really my first thought to sniff someone.
I don't know, is that... I guess...
For you guys, it's probably like first thought, huh?
Jirozaki, thank you!
Getting this game just to see if it's really as hard as you've shown.
It's probably... It'll probably be easier for you guys, I bet.
If you try this game, you'll probably do better than I will. For sure.
I'm gonna say, thank you.
Oh, thank you. Very comfy.
I've been out of college, thank you so much for the big stuff.
Thank you, thank you.
No, I haven't eaten any pizza off the bathroom floor.
I think.
But I know of.
Thank you so much for the support.
The Rock. Thank you. Wow, The Rock. The real The Rock.
Can I say it? Thank you. Yes, Happy Lady Valentine's Day, everyone.
X-Wow, thank you. Bubba Day is June 2nd.
Bubba Day, Bubba Day. Contest, thank you. Hello, Reddit.
Eskoma, thank you.
How do Gooda's feet feel? Well, I had my feet under the coffee table.
You know, and I had them in the middle because nobody else had their feet under the coffee table.
And Gura was sitting like across from me.
And then, you know, later into the stream she decided to put her feet under there.
In my territory, okay? I was there first.
And, uh, yeah we were both wearing socks.
That was pretty soft I guess.
The socks were soft. And warm.
But everything there was like soft and warm. It was nice.
The carpet was really soft. The cats were really soft.
It was nice.
Okay. I'm gonna end the stream now.
I'm gonna go check out the karaoke.
Oh my god, the dropped frames are 0.2% which is 666.
Dropped frames! What does it mean?
Okay, you guys have two more minutes and then I'm ending the stream.
I can get it at 1.50.
Aye! Spooky!
Thank you for the stream, thank you guys for watching!
I've not used a kotatsu before.
Never used before.
What am I eating?
What am I eating? I'm not eating anything right now but today I had some leftover
meat darashidango. I had pineapple and I've been trying to eat a lot of veggies so
I got some vegetable curry with some chicken on the side. That's what I had for dinner
and honestly I've been eating a lot of udon also. I love like as a konbine, like the market, they
They have this take home udon thing and it comes with like, not frozen, but like congealed broth jelly.
Sounds weird, but the noodles are sitting on top of like these cubes of jelly and then you microwave it and they melt and then it turns into tasty broth.
I don't know, I love udon so much. Udon is so good!
Instant udon? No, it's like pre-prepared
Do I eat together with other members?
Yeah, we've been going to eat at some places
We had like yakiniku
And we had some... I don't know...
I don't know what kind of place it was
Oh yeah, it had a... What is it called? A bulgogi
Yeah, tasty bulgogi
Bugogi? Bugogi
And...had...what else?
I can't think of anything else. Oh, we've gone to like, cafes, some cafes
We had some cake together
We went to like, a family restaurant
We had some tasty food
That a little robot brought us.
Very tasty.
Nah, I haven't been to a maid cafe.
I've never been.
Never been.
Yeah, we're gonna do GeoGuessr collab, but we still have a long time to plan it, and we're all kind of busy at the moment.
I think just now we're getting a few breaker days, but I don't wanna be like, you know...
Alright, come on, let's get on this!
Everybody's been working really hard, so...
Having some nice, relaxing time...
To ourselves, we'll be good.
And then...we'll fit in collabs here and there.
Especially after...
You know, we finish a lot of the bulk of the 3D streams.
We'll have time.
Alright...
I'm gonna end the stream now. Thank you guys for watching.
I'll see you tomorrow, special guest collab!
Woah woah woah! Let's go!
Let's go with it, bye!